i remember having a conversation with
you
at uh what's that earth bar we were
there to get our healthy juices oh yeah
bumped into each other and i was telling
you about uh how i had trouble with
relationships and how i was uh seeking
sexual sobriety
yeah you you actually can i just i want
to be completely honest with you
out of all the human beings i've ever
met on planet earth i'm almost 50 and
two weeks i'll be 50 years old
and you are the most one of the most
fascinating people
i've ever encountered in my life i'll
tell you why because i've never seen
a human being go through such a
transformation than you
it's like you're the poster child of
like that like 12 steps of work and you
know what i mean and all that stuff
works because it's like when i first met
you bro i thought you were like a human
scab
yeah
yeah yeah you were like just this thing
you know like he would walk in the room
and we kind of
you know kind of you know oh you know
like what the [ __ ] yeah you know i mean
and it's like was the first time we met
uh when i got kicked out of that uh
video game awards was it a video game
[Music]
that was awards craziest
dude i remember you had to show up to to
rehearse the show you were just running
vegas right yeah it's the video games
awards right samuel jackson's hosting
and we're doing the rehearsal
right first of all i'm so i'm supposed
to present with you we're co-presenters
right well we were we were supposed to
that was the intention yeah that was the
intention right
then all of a sudden like you know you
you're a little late so i'm already
there at the where i'm supposed to be my
mark
you come in
and you start screaming at
samuel jackson
you go what are you doing that's for
you
and i remember being so in the audience
was because there were other presenters
in the audience it was pat oswald and
brian hussein
and i remember them looking at me and
pat oswalt looks at me and he goes with
his mouth i'm so sorry
right next thing i know they drag you
out
right
and then next thing i hear is that
you're banned from the mgm
uh for life or something like that yeah
i mean okay something happened backstage
i don't know what happened right but
that like that was like my first
encounter with you yeah what year would
this have been uh
maybe
2007 sounds about maybe yeah and i
remember i had to present by myself
you know i mean so now the live show
you got to present by yourself i got to
present my bible stuff but i would love
to do it with you
but you were like out of your mind that
was the first time we met and then the
second time we met yeah was at the this
super high end
fancy
massage place it's called burke williams
yeah i don't think i was yet sober at
that point
but then to see you go from there
right to like
vegan to like you know i mean you know i
mean i'm not masturbating for next for a
year
430 days yeah i'm you know i mean i'm
sober
i live a clean life and just being like
this transformation that like just kind
of blew my mind
because you know when you get sober i
still have like
my things right like you know i i smoke
oh you do yeah i see you know i still
sometimes masturbate to porn
like in in a very like
you know alcoholic way you know oh yeah
like what there are many different
approaches to masturbating to porn what
do you mean i mean people there are
people like scott randolph who would put
like i went nine times in one day before
why
well i don't know how do you masturbate
alcoholically well it's like
the motto that i was raised with if a
little is good a lot's better yeah but
by the ninth time your dick must have
looked like a dog's dick like like a
licorice yeah i wasn't too worried about
that was it bleeding no i don't know i
don't really remember too much you can
come out when you like little visine
drops came out after you can and then
there's then there's other people who
just for like one for one orgasm we'll
spend like 10 hours that's what that's
what i do they said you're like i'm
about to come right and then i'll just
release
right and i'll let it even go down
yeah so you're in it's called edging is
that what it's called it's called edging
you get right to the edge right then you
back off i back off so so you'd actually
put out i mean that's like such a time
suck yeah my penis goes
and it goes
i wonder if that's good for you i think
it's that i don't think it's good it's
not because there's nothing good about
it there's nothing good your heart is
right
when i went to the therapist he was like
do you masturbate like
in two minutes or do you like take you
ten hours and i was like oh like two
minutes and i was like yeah got it and
he wrote a note but i'll tell you why
it's not good
it's because
you know i went to
i went to a place because when my dad
died you know what i mean all this
is all these issues came up because my
dad used to beat the [ __ ] out of me
growing up and all this trauma came up
and i couldn't eat or sleep i relapsed i
relapsed you know i have two years
almost now but a couple years ago i
relapsed and i um i couldn't eat or
sleep for months i lost like 40 pounds i
was on the i was on i was gonna kill
myself right so then i went to a
therapist
and we talked about my upbringing and
the trauma so then i went to a place in
arizona right so when i was in arizona i
signed a contract because it's like they
said you not only you know i got sober
but they're like um
when you masturbate to porn because i
have trauma you have to understand the
people that are in porn also went
through trauma and it's just like a
cycle of like
um so this is the place in arizona the
general path no i went to a place called
p
s
c or something like that
but anyway but anyway
you know when you that's why i haven't
been to strip clubs either because it's
like it's just like yeah these
women are just you know i mean they just
had i'm not saying all of them but like
you know a lot of them have gone through
tremendous amounts of trauma and this
and that it's just not a healthy yeah
well
you know but i still sometimes
masturbate it's called stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude